hello my name is Josh Malaya
I'm a senior marketing product manager
at an opening biotech and today's
webinar will be on the automated cell
separation for drug discovery assays
today the agenda will be as follows
first we're going
little bit about the background of
Milton E biotech and how we are pioneers
in cellular therapy next we'll talk
about the isolation of primary cells
moving beyond density gradient
centrifugation next we will talk about
the automated isolation of primary cells
this is for reproducibility and
scalability and then finally we'll talk
about drug discovery assays and some
example applications
Milton in biotech was founded in 1989 by
Stephan Milton II in the basis of
Maxwell isolation is column technology
developed as a part of his diploma
thesis and this was patented in 1990
already in the beginning stages
Stephan Metheny had a pioneering spirit
and saw the potential for max technology
to become a revolutionize er in the
field of gene therapy the cleaner Mac
cd34 reagent system is a method for
selecting hematopoietic stem cells from
donor apheresis while passively
depleting t-cells that can cause
graft-versus-host disease the
development went on for over 20 years
including setting up a GMP manufacturing
site in tetro Germany and finally the
cd4 cd34 isolation using the Clinton
Mac's together with the Clinton Mac's
cd34 reagent which received FDA approval
in 2014 what started out as one man's
diploma thesis has since grown into a
global company of more than 2,500
employees worldwide in over 20,000
scientific publications citing Mac's
technology annually more than 2,500
patients receive sell products
manufactured with no pending biotech
technologies
the phrase is empowering discovery in
advancing therapy get to the core of our
company's mission which is to improve
scientific understanding and medical
progress by providing solutions that
advance biomedical research and cellular
therapies and we achieve this mission by
our ongoing commitment of bringing newer
and smarter technologies to the
scientists and clinicians who are paving
the way to longer and healthier lives
[Applause]
technology is based on three basic
principles first you have the magnetic
labeling where an antibody conjugated to
a tiny paramagnetic micro bead binds to
a receptor or protein on the cell
surface there are different strategies
for this step which will be covered in
more detail later in the presentation
next we have magnetic separation the
process where cells are passed through a
column that is positioned within a
magnet the cell is labeled with the
micro bead are retained within the
column where as everything else passes
through in a gentle way the flow through
is called the negative fraction
containing the cells without the ligand
or antibody that was used the aleutian
step the column is removed from the
magnet enabling the paramagnetic ly
labeled cells meaning that the
microbeads lose their magnetic system
outside of the separator allowing them
to pass freely through the column this
can be achieved through a quick manual
step using a plunger to gently loop the
cells or via an equally gentle automated
process using a vacuum to pull the cells
out by increasing the flow speed of the
buffer in the system these methods are
all gentle on themselves and separate
them into negative and positive
fractions with exceptional purity and
high viability max technology is
therefore based on three key components
microbead
column and the max magnetic separator
there
several versions of each available and
depending on your starting material cell
type of interest and whether using a
manual or automated system since the
column is the heart of Max technology
let's take a quick look at the benefits
and why it is clearly the superior
choice when compared to column three
methods
you
the magnetic separators and column-based
and column-free systems have a
comparable magnetic force the difference
between the systems is a column filled
with little iron spheres that pass the
magnetic force over on to the next one
over a very small distance amplifying
the magnetic force by ten thousandfold
benefit is that minimum labeling of the
cells with microbeads is sufficient to
retain the target cells within the
column while in the separator the iron
spheres have a so friendly coating that
allows cells to run freely through the
column and can be washed thoroughly to
remove cell debris and contaminants all
of this contributes to the fact that max
columns allow for cell separation with
minimal effects on cells combined these
advantages make max columns the best
choice or cell separation for drug
discovery applications
you
before we get into the specifics of
primary cell isolation let's consider
the use of primary cells and cell lines
in the drug discovery process primary
cells are sourced directly from human or
animal tissues whereas cell lines on the
other hand are generated by
immortalizing primary cells with vectors
and cultivating them over many passages
the cell cultures that result that that
result differ fastly regarding the
tissue of origin cellular
characteristics and actual relevance to
predict in vivo biology
starting with primary cells they have a
relatively limited supply of blood
donations are needed and there's quite a
bit of variability when it comes with
the quality and consistency these cells
have a limited proliferation in culture
as well as a limited lifespan you can
see high donor by variability and
depending on what you want this can be
either a positive or negative
characteristic necessary for
immunogenicity and biomarker discovery
whereas it's not wanted in screening or
banking for optimization of molecules
these cells have a relatively low
mutation rate and this preserves in vivo
characteristics giving you no surprising
modifications it has the same genetic
makeup of the original tissue
these cells have a more representative
biological phenotype and complexity the
physiological and clinical relevant
phenotypes that these cells offer are
also a benefit
these films are pre characterized and
are ready to use
and this can comparing this to cell
lines there are a lot of differences
these cells are virtually unlimited in
supply they're easy to culture almost
indefinitely
there's no donor variation however many
cell lines are often misidentified and
also can can be contaminated with other
cells this gives you the danger of false
positives these cells have a relatively
high mutation late mutation rate and so
on is often mutate so that their genetic
and phenotypic characteristics are no
longer representative of those from the
original donor cells either through the
immortalization process or afterwards
they have relatively low relevance in
vivo and are often used on research
that's focused on it's very specific
target and lastly the authentication
that is needed in these cells is a major
concern misidentified and cross
containment and contaminated cell lines
as a major issue in a recent study of
over 500 Leukemia and Lymphoma cell
lines 15% of those cell lines were
misidentified
most primary cells come from human
derived blood products such as luke wax
Buffy coats horrible end
in the United States and Canada Milton a
biotech is now offering Lou kopacz bone
marrow and whole blood if you have in
from have any interest in this please
visit our website or come to the booth
for additional information
on the other hand can be a murine or
human origin and can be either healthy
such as spleen or lymph nodes or
diseased tissue such as tumors these
include patient-derived xenograft and
mice which are also often used in the
drug discovery process
this sample preparation step is mostly
density gradient centrifugation to get
PBMCs
or in the case of tissue dissociation of
the tissue for example with the gentle
max this is dissociated to get a single
cell suspension after this you can
proceed with the cell separation
isolation strategies can vary depending
on your project and we have a wide
selection of different options to suit
your needs would you rather go for a
fast and easy positive isolation or do
you need all of your epitopes free for a
second sort requiring an untouched
isolation where you label everything
else but the population of interest or
do you have multiple samples and would
prefer a separate to separate them in
parallel rather than sequentially are
you freezing aliquot C or PBMCs or
isolated cells directly all of these
factors are important when deciding on
which cell separation strategy is right
for you
once you have your population of
interest you can move on to the
downstream application whether it's an
additional separation step for
subpopulations for example T regs or
flow cytometry for amino phenotyping we
can recommend kits that will make these
steps easier are you culturing
yourselves for in vitro assays or
running genomics and proteomics
applications whether you are interested
in maximum recovery for cell culture
assays or high purity for reliable
genomics or proteomics toady's studies
we can help you with the strategy to get
there
we'll next focus on we will now focus on
PBMC isolation for drug discovery
applications such as immunity no typing
and in vivo functional assays
to recap traditional approaches go from
blood products to PBMCs to target cells
and to steps in this process you have to
go from a blood sample to PBMCs via
density gradient centrifugation I'm sure
that many of you unfortunately know this
process quite well there are a number of
steps required to isolate PD mcs via
density gradient centrifugation first
you have to carefully layer your blood
sample over the gradient then centrifuge
the sample for 20 to 30 minutes with no
break which is one of the most
infuriating aspects of this process
followed by a highly variable PBMC
recovery process and wash and for
subsequent target cell isolation and
accurate cell count this process makes
takes more than two hours and can easily
eat up most of your morning depending on
the number of samples that you have to
process
straight from microbeads are the hassle
free alternative to density gradient
centrifugation our straight from product
line allows for the isolation of cells
directly from blood products without
density gradients without cell counting
and in only a few simple steps with
minimal hands-on time and user variation
our straight from products offer the
fastest available protocol for target
cell isolation from buffy coats and Luco
packs
really simple you transfer
the Buffy coat Lucca pack or LRS scene
into a suitable container and fill it up
to 80 mils that the volumes are less
than that this example is for a buffy
coat but it's similar if you're working
with an LRS see or Luca pack add the
microbeads and incubate in the fridge
after which you can separate the cells
using the multi-max 24 we'll get to the
instruments in a little bit you can go
from an entire buffy coat to target
cells in as little as 25 minutes or from
half a Luca pack in 40 minutes
finally you have another option to
density gradient centrifugation military
bio tank is excited to introduce our
straight from microbeads for the direct
isolation of target cells from blood
products and we've just launched our new
products for Buffy coats leuco packs and
LR FCS to summarize thus far we've now
learned about primary cells what we need
to consider when planning a project to
isolate cells the steps to isolate them
from tissue or blood products as well as
the shortcuts we can take everything
we've talked about aims at generating
asking results that are biologically
relevant reproducible and as efficient
as possible
saving hands on time and unnecessary
repetitive steps however the reagents we
work with are only half of the solution
truly efficient protocols with
reproducible results require automation
so I'd like to take a few moments to
discuss automated solutions before going
on to discuss drug discovery assays
so what is the benefit of having
automation automation reduces hands-on
time and to work on more other important
a that cannot be automated if minimum it
minimizes variation between different
users in the lab or even good and bad
days of an individual scientist and of
course it minimizes costly human errors
with standardized protocols and minimal
user variation you can be sure that the
effects that you're seeing our duty are
a say rather than artifacts in short
automation reduces redundant experiments
and allows you to focus your time where
it matters
Milton T biotech has developed various
automated solutions for the isolation of
target cells for various drug
development assays
you
with the auto maxpro separator the
easy-to-use benchtop instrument for
every lab with fully automated
sequential separation of one to six
samples the auto maxpro provides easy
access to automation without the high
investment cost or lots of training you
can run if you can isolate cells from
different starting materials in one run
press the start button and the
instrument will label and separate the
cells for you the columns are reusable
so maintenance is easy and there are
preset programs for high recovery and
high purity depending on your downstream
applications if you have more than six
samples or large samples such as buffie
codes you might want to consider
parallel cell isolation the multi-max
family is perfect for this 24 columns
allow you to process 1 to 24 samples in
one run or split your large sample
between multiple columns this is
achieved by using the LS LD or whole
blood columns or the multi 24 block for
easy handling of 24 samples or an entire
Lugo pack the multi-max cell 24 is a
semi automated instrument and a good fit
for many labs that value easy handling
but don't mind the manual piping however
if you want full automation and maximum
throughput you will love the multi-max
acts which integrates a multi max 24
into a liquid handler
lost in 2017 this is the instrument for
the demanding high throughput cell
processing lab samples are labeled and
isolated automatically and you can go
from the entire Buffy code to target
cells in 30 minutes or from a Luca pack
in 60 minutes all programs are tailored
to meet your needs and we won't leave
your lab until you are satisfied with
the protocol and the results
in summary the auto maxpro is great for
small samples and low throughput with
full automation for example in
processing PBMC a loquats now samples or
patient-derived xenograft because the
automatic scan process whole blood
without cycle is also great for patient
samples or small donor samples on the
other hand the multi-max family are the
high throughput variants for fast
parallel processing for example of small
or human mouse lamp small human or mouse
samples but also for large blood
products such as buffy goats in Lugo
packs
we've now learned about the steps of
primary cell isolation and how to ensure
maximum efficiency and reproducibility
by selecting the best reagents and
instruments to match your workflow at
this point I'd like to take a chance to
go through some of the application data
from the assays frequently run in the
drug discovery process at different
stages this includes phenotypic
screening for target discovering animal
model development and toxicity or any
know Jenna city we'll start with a
phenotypic or high-content screening
phenotypic screening can be used for
biologic and small molecule development
the example here is small molecules
where we've looked at the binding of NC
p1 to CCR 2 on the surface of monocytes
using high content screening in the
development of an anti-inflammatory drug
a CCR 2 inhibitor CCR 2 is expressed on
monocytes and is the binding site for
MVP 1 a chemo kind that attracts and
activates monocytes in the top row you
will see the blue monocytes on the left
and the red mCP 1 in the middle in the
overlay show that the cells and the mCP
one are co-localize in the middle row
unlabeled MCP one was added in excess to
block all - ID binding sites and as you
can see no stain MVP 1 can be detected
the same is seen when the CCR 2
inhibitor which is the potential drug is
added and there's no mCP 1 signal since
there are no free binding sites
additional information can then be
acquired on a single cell level for
example the shape and size of the
cytoplasm as well as dynamic information
about the nucleus
another example of drug discovery assays
that utilize cell separation is the
development of mouse models this example
is the humanization of the mouse first
you would irradiate the mouse then
transplant human cd34 positive Amado
poetic stem cells isolated on the
automax pro after infusing these cells
into the mouse into the irradiated mouse
allows you to grow a humanized immune
system of course you can then monitor
the success of this humanization by
isolating human immune cells
subpopulations after infusion
in the later stages of the drug
development process you will be needing
lots of primary cells for the mechanism
of action profiling of your drug
candidates to understand the exact
mechanisms by which the drugs influences
the immune system which concentrations
are needed and in which combinations in
the example of a mixed lymphocyte
reaction you will isolate mana size from
one donor and T cells from another donor
you will differentiate the monocytes and
two dendritic cells and combine them
with the T cells from the second donor
this combination will lead to the
activation of the T cells and by adding
various checkpoint inhibitors these
molecules will unleash the brakes and
enhance the reaction the T cell
activation can be tracked for example by
interferon gamma production as we will
show on the next slide
the t-cells and controls by themselves
show low levels of t-cell activation
however when you add a PD one antibody
or a PDL one antibody you can show
significantly increased interferon gamin
production in all three donor pairs of
the sign of the drug candidate enhancing
the immune reaction
another method of MOA profiling is the
t-rex oppression a saying here you
isolate cd4 cells and T reg cells you
simulate the cd4 cells and then combine
them in Co culture during the co culture
you can track the inhibition of the
t-cell activation by the T regs and by
adding the drug compound of interest you
can detect compounds that can suppress
the T reg inhibitory effect as you can
see on this graph on the right the same
method can also be used for MDS C
suppression assays which are based on
the same principle
as an example of a killing assay in the
T cell dependent cellular cytotoxicity I
seen you isolate panty cells and culture
them with EGFR positive cancer cells in
this case CDs three EGFR by specific
antibodies bring these T cells and
cancer cells together for more efficient
killing which can be monitored in an ATP
based readout for example a cell titer
glow luminescence as in this example
phenyl isolation is also essential in
carpi research you can monitor the
transduction activation and killing as
well as manipulate the effector to
target cell ratios for example here you
isolate T cells transducing them for
example with a prostate cancer specific
antigen PSMA and culture the cells and
culture the transduce Cartier's with two
cell lines one antigen positive and 1
antigen negative a TD CC as they might
follow to monitor the killing as we just
discussed the output looks like this
where we have our PSMA positive cell
line in black in the PSM a negative cell
line in gray in the first test on the
right you test for transduction
efficiency with a cd19 car as a positive
control comparing the two different car
contracts on the top right you see that
the PSM a positive car key constructs
are specifically activated using cd25 as
an activation marker when in contact
with an antigen positive cell cancer
line the lysis is equally specific in
this antigen specific reaction is
exactly what you want to see
small molecules - biologics we also have
one example from predictive
immunogenicity in the NHC associated
peptide proteomics assay you isolate the
monotypes of and differentiate them into
immature dendritic cells you then add
the biologic drug candidate of interest
afterwards you can then precipitate the
bound fragments to isolate the antibody
fragments that were presented on the dcs
and analyze the peptides by mass
spectrometry to see which ones are
presented and might activate the t-cells
the mass spectrometer and analysis of a
therapeutic antibody with the heavy and
light chains might look like this
you list all of your donors and map the
peptides that are presented in a seed
map for your specific antibody this heat
map can then be used to modify the an
ahmadi to D immunize it and make it
safer regarding immunogenicity
the next step of predictive
immunogenicity is the DCT cell assay
here you isolate monocytes that act as
antigen presenting cells you call
culture them with T cells and you add a
candidate antibody or a mix of peptides
from your fragmented antibody and see if
cd4 positive T cells proliferate and
produce il-2 indicating that in
immunological reaction to this peptide
is occurring this can be tracked by
using flow cytometry measuring the cd4
proliferation and il-2 production using
the cytokine release assay on the right
you see the correlation of an in vitro
versus clinical data that show that if a
drug shows immuno genic genetic effects
and the in vitro studies it is highly
likely to cause problems in the patient
as well
most of what we have talked about today
revolves around drugs the drug discovery
process that is ultimately aimed at
producing drugs for patients to this end
we have a translational approach from
bench top to bedside that is reflected
in all of our products we provide the
same product and research grade as well
as GMP and clinic and clinical quality
to ensure smooth transition into the
clinic we provide the entire workflow
for products for cell based work from
tissue dissociation and homogenize ation
to cell isolation and culture including
activation and expansion as well as cell
analysis
so to summarize primary cells are a
valuable model for biologically relevant
assay results reliable results depend on
the right cell isolation strategies and
we've learned that you can reduce human
error and improve efficiency with
automated solutions in every stage of
drug discovery
with this I invite you to come and visit
the virtual booth to learn more about
our offerings I thank you for your time
and please let me know if you have any
questions
thank you
you